what was it like when you received that
call that you would be headlining the
halftime show it was so scary because it
was kind of unexpected to come back from
like zero to the Super Bowl like that's
kind of nuts getting back to anything
right now has to feel worth it nothing
is like worthy of your time away from
your kid before my firstborn came I was
good on my own that's the way it was
that sounded like the lyric of mine it
wasn't literally
people want to know are there any
surprises I'm thinking about bringing
someone a word I'm not sure okay you can
tell me off camera when we cut the
cameras off no
now you can catch the exclusive sneak
peek interview tonight on NFL Plus at 8
pm Eastern to sign up just scan the QR
code on your screen right now